oh hey are you Brian you David yeah hey
thank you so much for doing this I
really appreciate it well that's no
trouble to me I saw your ad on
Craigslist
I know these storage lockers well but
this does provide college credit right
well it's unpaid the rest is up to you
but aren't you a little old to be in
college yeah I'm trying to finish what
had happened was I went into a coma in
my 20s I mixed ambien with a Terrence
Malick movie well you must have been in
a dark place
I was a theater basically I need you to
interview me for a podcast you know
build some buzz hoping that happened
organically but no one booked me on
hairs how about this David
tell me about I wrote some questions for
you David what do you think of the
current state of comedy well I think
it's great you know a lot of diversity
all types of comics now and in the old
days it was almost exclusively funny
people should I laugh if you want to
David why do you think the industry has
scorned you so unfairly well I wouldn't
say that no no I just think Hollywood
doesn't know what to do with me it's
like if I was 5% funnier I'd be a
millionaire and if I was 30% less funny
I'd be a multimillionaire
ha ha okay
David the Hollywood establishment has
clearly marginalized you what is it that
they're afraid of well I've always been
kind of a rebel you know and comics
today they're not like that they all
want to be on TV you know if you want to
speak truth to power you got to get your
teeth whitened there's no edge no
defiance anymore in comedy or anywhere
really well there is one place
you lost pal no I'm just surprised as
I'm at the library yeah it's sick right
every since all the dive bars and clubs
turned into like cupcake shops and
condos we got to find a new place to
sleep and take shits and it's got free
internet grab a seat
Thanks so what's your deal man what do
you do I'm a comedian what do you mean
like a clown or something that's more
like a mime a mime talked what's the
point of that exactly right on I guess
how did you get into the scene you know
what man I just stopped giving up
could you please shut up this is a
library no it's not it's like a homeless
jackoff Center that rents films to poor
people nobody's happy
that was awesome and thirty years ago
this is where nerds hung out and now
it's like this stronghold of
anti-establishment whatever satisfies
the soul is truth Walt Whitman well I'm
just happy you guys are here you know
doing your thing there are no rules only
options Whitman yeah Jerry is he dead
I hope so cool so there are cool people
at the library and that really well
there was this one guy Jerry who seemed
kind of fun the guy that did heroin yeah